[Music]
the cast and crew of the bold and
beautiful celebrate 30 years with
original cast members jaundice cook and
captain Kelly Lane mr. mcquewick 30
years on the bold and beautiful years I
get a cupcake with my picture on I mean
does it feel like 30 years of fast no it
feels like 5 or 10 you know I know I've
been here a while but but 30 is hard to
wrap my brain around forget about me
identify for now we're just talking
about how 30 years on the bold and
beautiful now you get cupcakes with your
face on them I know that it's crazy does
it feel like 30 years of stuff yeah when
you think about it now I think the first
10 years came to be the longest and then
time just flew by and the new people
come all the time new characters are
coming and are good you know there's
anything new as you see into the
storyline and new energy so I imagine
that the love scenes are a lot different
when you're first starting up and save
30 years later well they're probably
more fun you know what kind of a thing
hello wow this is all fun and new and
but you know after 30 years of doing
love teens and it does clapping spread
it's kind of maybe we're going to make
our Kelly again it right Jenna I could
do worse I could be a lot of good things
how would you sum up your experience on
the bold and beautiful in one world were
each comfortable
it's one word give me three if you have
it
alcohol and beautiful
[Applause]